[Music]
so as a guy that that works at Fox
you're in the cable news thing I think
the question I get more than anything
else these days is who do you trust
how do you figure out when you're going
through the research on what you're
gonna talk about on the 5 or what you're
gonna cover on on your show how do you
figure out what's actually legit well
that's interesting because I never I
mean I I read this stuff and then I
talked to people then I asked him if
what they think we have up we have
people at Fox who have something called
the brain room
if I'm I'm skeptical of a number and
they're like they're good this is like a
group of people in a room that just
spend all day fielding questions that's
why they're called the brain room and if
I have a problem with something I'll go
to him but if I smell anything I won't
touch it like if there's if there's a
story that I just go if something sounds
too good then it's you know it's not
it's just too perfect and you always
like there's weird stories like where
you go will you find like woman's child
sent home for singing America the
Beautiful while petting a kitten well
you know what I mean it's like it's like
it always it sounds like just such
perfect red meat and then you find out
somebody makes a few phone calls you
find out it's not true they kid like you
know punched some kid suspended a lot of
these stories that sound like they would
be perfect never pan out so I just I
think I'm just super skeptical of
everything and and I'm careful
I'm probably the best thing to do is you
let a story breathe for a couple of days
never be the first one never jump on
something because you're it's like every
I regret every time I've ever jumped on
a story because it's never been right
it's this has to have happened and you
go it's like you know when you get I
hate to admit this but getting getting
falling for a hoax like yeah I I think I
felt for something there was a hoax on
Twitter about a Burger King
remember the Burger King tweets the guy
in Hong Kong the Burger King tweets and
he was right he was
Burger King tweets an enemy he was going
my life is horrible and I thought this
was oh my god and it turned out it was
this guy had been hoaxing for like six
months
I go that okay he got me so I have to
like I have to
I always said go like okay this if this
just is too delicious a story wait two
days I won't do it on any show that's
the other benefit of doing a weekly show
is you get to kind of come in and and
see the mistakes then everybody else
made and go ah look look what he did he
thought it was real it like hopes yeah
I'll like take a like hate crime hoaxes
are a good example like if you just wait
a couple of days something happens and
it just like yeah like I knew it you
know well the one that always sticks
with me is remember the clock boy who
got you know kicked out of school and
everyone was going on and on about this
is based in racism and Islamophobia and
all this stuff but if you looked at what
he brought into school it looked like a
bomb I mean it just it just did and we
live in a time when they say if you see
something say something so if a little
white girl had brought that thing in you
know or a little white boy that's those
are the people the left thinks are evil
so shouldn't they have called in on that
and then of course there was a ton other
shady things that happened after this
area president obviously running for
president of I can't remember was in
Afghanistan I can't remember but he yes
I think the family moved to Qatar and so
and all that but even that doesn't
matter but I just remember thinking
during that thing that you the media
portrayed it in such one way that if I
even had tweeted well just everything
aside I don't want this kid to be
treated differently but everything aside
if a kid any kid of any color brings
something that looks like a bomb it
didn't look like a clock it looked like
a bomb through school you would want
that would just be teachers doing their
due-diligence
but I didn't even want to touch it
because I didn't want to deal with this
and you know it was frustrating because
President Obama touched it he oh yeah
say like I'm gonna invite he could be
his son or something yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna invite yeah I think he was saying
that he said something he didn't fight
him to the White House for something and
I was like you know that's that it just
shows you that you can have these
blinders on and not see like you know
that there's a possibility that this is
a hoax and that there's something
going on but no if you you just he's in
the he's in the Islamophobia bubble
where you know everybody has terrible
intentions rather than just trying to be
safe they see something that looks like
a bomb
that's not Islamophobia but he says oh
this poor kid is being targeted because
he he's just doing a science project you
know and it's like no people were just
worried that's what they're supposed to
do it looks like a bomb
so his bubble prevented him from seeing
them no no how do you blend some of the
I've said to a couple of people when I
when I do your show that one of the
things that I like is cuz you kind of
you're like doing the cable news thing
and you get the online thing like this
for example when you when you go up to
your PR people or whoever handles
coordinates or stuff do they say to you
gutfeld you can't say this or don't
touch this or anything you've been
remotely close to that because I think
that's what a lot of people think is
happening at at Fox and a lot of the
other evil networks
I think they you know they're pretty
free about it you know no one has ever
told me not to say anything you know and
and and I think they are so understand
the difference however when I swear on
Twitter I usually get a light I used to
get a little grief like do you really
have to say that I'm gonna go I go look
I know it's I have a theory knive my own
theories on swearing that I don't
understand I don't understand the
concept of swearing like like what is
this word do we're all like don't swear
in front of my children
your kids are going to swear so what
you're trying to do is just put it up as
long as possible don't swear in front of
my kid go you know in five years your
kid's gonna be swearing anyway so it's
like everybody swears it's like pooping
in fact it's it's just like pooping it's
therapeutic you can't hold it in if you
keep holding it it's like if if you
couldn't swear what would you do if you
stubbed your toe you would punch
somebody
so the swearing keeps you from punching
people just like pooping that was a
terrible analogy but between point
there's always one moment in a show
where I go ah we got the promo clip for
Twitter and I feel it was looped around
that pooping analogy it always ends up
there I apologize
people always tell me too many poop
jokes and that wasn't a poop joke but
like that's that's an issue with no
before yeah yeah it was a it was a
useful metaphor right yeah that what you
said I I said it was a poop metaphor not
a useful metaphor poop but not but
swearing like I I find it weird that we
pretend that swearing doesn't exist you
know what I mean it's just an onion when
we like you'll be on TV if you if I
swear on TV I I will get fired or I'll
get suspended but all of us when we go
out into the green room or go somewhere
else we're just like what you know
whatever we're saying when it's just
such a weird thing to say well we have
to pretend like the world out there is a
different world and I get it it's
because you're in somebody's living room
and you should respect their living room
and be polite but but but I just don't
see how swearing is rude I don't
understand it
yeah but is that is that kind of one of
the inherent problems of not necessarily
cable news but television and news in
general that it's creating this fake
thing like I get what you're saying
about the the living room and trying to
be respectful of people and I don't
curse that much every now and again I
drop the f-bomb if I think it's
particularly appropriate but then when
you have this sort of fake guarded thing
coming through the television then
people go online they see this
completely unfiltered thing now it could
be filled with nonsense and lies and
fake names and BS and all that but
they're going at it at least seems a
little more real than the guy who can't
curse but you know what the flip side of
that is when you look at somebody's
description on Twitter god-fearing
grandparents of three lovely children
and their writing [ __ ] you burn in hell
on Twitter and it's like it's like okay
you're a guide like it's so funny to see
that like so that tells you that
everybody swears yeah everybody swears
but anyway
it's real to me because I love that I
love that crew I love that crew the the
tolerance peace love in the Twitter
handle [ __ ] Ruben it's me it's amazing
that they forget they wrote that up
there and they're saying terrible things
in their tweets it's it's always really
I mean it's a lot of people do a tour of
my you always like when somebody says
something
horrible - you remind them what's in
there what's in there below their avatar
it's like you do realize that you say
that you're like loving this and loving
that and you know or I'll ask them if
they're if they're kids if they write to
me on Facebook I ask that I always tell
them I'm gonna put this on your Facebook
page and then they always apologize cut
felt I think we've learned something
here which is Twitter is destroying the
country it is it is the it is did I say
this here are on break that I yeah I did
a study yes I think I did that the
people on Twitter yeah that was here
that was here a good job did I tell you
that ik this is what happens is I can't
remember what I said this just happened
but nope you know what not remembering
not remembering what you said also has
to do with Twitter as someone that just
took a month off doing that short
nonsense all the time it's like sir it's
short-circuiting all of our brains you
know yeah it's uh it's so gross it's
like I don't feel good after it I just
don't feel good about myself or the
world when I'm on there it's but you
know there's been a lot of unfortunate
events in the last month and you whether
we have the hurricanes and you see like
I think I said this on the five you see
so many inspirational acts during the
hurricane you see you know blacks
carrying whites whites carrying blacks
old ladies and young people and all this
stuff and then you go in Twitter and you
can realize okay what's real is what
people see like you can't like when
you're talking to somebody you treat
them as a human being on Twitter you
don't so use the contrast of how
horrible people are on Twitter is
precisely because they're not having the
human contact like a person could save
another person's life and those two
people could hate each other on Twitter
you know it's because it you have to
have for the sake of evolution and you
know this that you have to have eye
contact in hundred see people granted we
our community our animals of
communication so this is what we do and
it's not going to change
it's just that will we get any better or
are we gonna get worse that's what
scares me on that note let's shift away
from talking about Twitter how about
that every day I say I'm getting off it
and I don't yeah I'm a jerk you know
what we'll we'll revisit this in a
couple months
and see where we're at when you did I'm
gonna take a month off but I don't I
don't know if I can but I am two weeks
I'll take two weeks yeah do you ever
feel just putting the side social-media
do you ever feel that exhaustion of the
news I got a lot of that when I jump
back on I got so many emails from people
just saying man I wish I could do that
even for three days or even when I was
away the amount of people that were
staring at their phones you know of
course they're taking selfies and all
that nonsense but just you're I was on a
beach in Mexico for a couple days and at
one of the cafes they had CNN playing I
had to make sure not even to go in there
it's like why would you want to be on a
beach in Mexico and watching CNN it's
free it's freaky there it's like you
gotta get it yeah I always feel like
it's so much but then something else
happens and then you forget about what
just happened that's the weird thing is
that the cycle is so fast it wasn't
always like that that was what was
interesting about the hurricane was that
that was the first story that we had a
focus on for more than two days it went
on for like with the Houston hurricane
we got Harvey we at we spent eight days
on that and then we went right into Erma
that's it that's the first time in a
long time since probably the Trump meal
well I guess the election that was spent
every day on one thing we didn't cover
anything else maybe that's healthy that
like it we reengineered my brain a
little where I had to concentrate but I
do get I get um I don't really watch TV
when I get home I like like a set like
I'll watch Bar rescue what do you call
it when they're just just over and over
again
it's just they keep date they had them
overlap so I can't like I just sit there
I haven't seen this bar yet and I just
watched the marathon and all of a sudden
it's like 9 o'clock at night
I just watched like 12 episodes and some
of them I'd seen before if you you know
listen if you think you're dealing with
some filth in the news I mean that Jon
Taffer guy he's going to the back of
those bars there is some nasty it would
make you never want to go to a bar again
there is some nasty now she's like what
do you do it's gonna die because this
girl's eyes and you think they're gonna
get in a fight and then they're and then
all of a sudden are they
and everything's good and they always
find dead bugs in an inn and there's
always a rodent under a sofa and I look
and I know that show backwards and foot
step forwards net it's like and then
they turn around for the surprise and
like that that surprised it's just
another bar there's always a mouse in
the refrigerator in the back but
actually that bit there's something
interesting you're hitting on there I
think a little bit like when a guy like
him you know he's doing obviously it's
not news it's a it's a reality show but
the yelling because in in cable news
when when you know you know some of
these people I don't need you to call
out anybody at your network or even
another network but although feel free
to if you'd like to but how much of it
for these guys for a lot of these guys
do you think is theater versus actually
knowing what they're talking about or
caring what they're talking about
because what I think is that a lot of
people the average person doesn't
realize how much actually is pure
theater for ratings that at the end of
the day these networks they need views
they need eyeballs they need clicks and
if they're gonna give a guy who's gonna
calmly explain an issue and say you know
what climate change I believe in science
but I think that maybe you know they're
they're forcing something down whatever
it is right that guy is always gonna be
rammed to the bottom of the pack by the
guys who's gonna scream like yeah it's
and it might be a wrong assumption to
think that like a Booker goes get this
guy oh he's great and you go why is he
great and oh you got a huge for you
should see him on this show but that I
think it's might be changing because I
think the audience attitudes are
changing they I don't think they like
the yelling anymore
I don't you don't have as many crossfire
moments yeah and when you do it and like
I know from the five when there's a
crossfire moment the response the
audience doesn't like media I will put
it up there up so it so melts down blah
blah but the audience doesn't like it
they're like going god I had to turn it
off when you and Juan yell at each other
I have to turn it off that's what
they'll say
and I got and remind myself how did how
did we get to the point were yelling
funny thing is like when it happens on
the five it is real it's like when we're
yelling it's actually real some other
shows that might not be I think old
school shows that we're like you know I
think it's I think it's changed it
funny that when you think about like
these assumptions of producers they
assume that like Jon Taffer hash to yell
all the time right because that that's
drama but I don't I don't like or else
they have the weird sinister music when
you weird like it sounds like a door
creaking or yeah or that they have to
show transition from night to day all
the stuff that they use they think is
what is what we want when no we would
like something different we're we're
bored with these we don't need somebody
yelling like it's like Kitchen
Nightmares what's-his-face
he's British he's British he's got black
hair he's British they're somebody help
me help me gordon ramsay gordon ramsay
yeah you used to do Kitchen Nightmares
and then that didn't change I don't know
the name of it here but it's a Hell's
Kitchen or something I don't know but
you do exactly the formula and after a
while it's like you know this was good
for for shows but you got it like mix it
up but I think table news is like I I
think it you know it's I think we're
sensing things are changing I think I
finally like you know it's I find Tucker
to be the most interesting interviewer
yeah like no notes like and he just
stares at the person what I do you've
been on my show I have 33 pages of notes
you had so much freaking paper there how
many trees do you kill you you're
literally it looks like it looks like a
beautiful mind on your desk you're
scribbling everywhere you're drawing
sharks Kimberley kill for who calls me
that because I have like all this stuff
it's only because I have I don't want to
miss anything and of course I do because
I have an idea or and I all these ideas
so I write them all down and I end up
having like 20 ideas and then I never
get to them because you guys have to
talk so I just like I don't even know
why that's there Tucker just sits there
and he just stares I always say he's
like a dog watching a dryer you know
this is like stairs and he's got this
look and it's the most intense interview
because like you could tell he's in the
moment like I'm not in the moment I'm
never I'm always ahead I'm always
somewhere else trying to figure out
what's what am I gonna ask Tyrus what am
I gonna do here blah blah blah but he's
just like so focused on the guest it's
unbelievable and he's like actually
listening to every single word
I find that like that's not me I try to
listen wait a minute you're telling me
you're not listening to the brilliance
that I bring to the gut I listen
actually I listen to good guests guess
who aren't good I'm too busy trying to
figure out how to get to the end of the
break boy this is this person isn't
working out I'm sure you've had that
look what a person isn't working out and
you're like oh god how do I get how do I
get from here to there well help me now
and every now and again I'll have a
guest that I'll just be like you're just
not saying anything you know like
sometimes people are just talking but
they're not really getting anywhere and
I try to lead them into something and
they still can't get there
fortunate doesn't have it doesn't happen
that often because I think we we select
pretty well but of course you're gonna
get that but you know your point on on
Tucker is interesting because you know I
was on there last week and I've been on
a couple of times and generally because
of the free speech stuff I'm not the
type of guest he's bringing on to hammer
but I always think it's amazing when
when he brings on these people that
should know what he's about to do and
it's like they just walk in there as if
it's gonna be like kumbaya and next
thing they know it's like you're
dragging out of corpse yeah did my
favorite one was the guy who thought he
could out Tucker Tucker Kurt I can Wald
do you remember that he brought a stack
of paper he said the and he was like he
brought a prop and it was one of the
most embarrassing things because all
Tucker did was laugh at him it was it
was just so it was painful they should
do a compilation as like when you go if
he goes on off one night they should do
Tucker's like most amazing interviews
and just have like I'm all like all of
these like crazies where the people come
in and think I'm gonna be the guy I'm
gonna be the guy that that that a beats
him or B he likes or whatever and he's
just it's just like you don't know where
he's gonna go and then I just look
really bad so so speaking of Tucker one
as I said before one of the reasons I
like doing this stuff right so you're
the Greg Gutfeld show is not it's live
to tape but it's not aired live when you
do the five it is aired live Tucker's
live and I always my gut feeling my gut
feeling you got that has anyone ever
said that to you before the gut feeling
my gut feeling is I like I like live
live straight-up because I know I'm not
going to be messed with now I know your
guys aren't gonna mess with me or edit
me or anything like that but when you're
doing the live thing when you're on the
5 you've it you've already had said that
you know you're not going to get
everything right all the time and you're
happy to be corrected but have you ever
just by the nature of the way the human
mind works started saying something and
by the time the sentence finished
realize that you just completely had no
idea what you were saying or something
like that like yeah you see this a lot
that all these people that have to talk
all the time every now and again you
start saying something and as it's
coming out of your mouth you go oh man I
just stepped in it yeah yeah yeah it's
always it's like it it's just best at
that point to trail off just like just
take the embarrassment rather I'm going
in a really bad direction you know it's
funny though I've noticed that whatever
you think is really bad is less bad than
you think
sometimes it's a goji's thing and then
nobody noticed that but there'll be
something else that you don't think is a
big deal and that's the one that gets
picked up and people say I can't believe
you said that and I go that's not what I
meant
and that kickback gets twisted and
turned you make an ironic joke that
they'll think you were serious like like
you were making fun of a person who
might say that you might maybe like you
might you're mocking a sexist by saying
something sexist and then someone will
say no you're sexist I go no I was
actually pretending to be sexist oh
forget it I can't do this
I'm like there's no way I'm gonna get
out of this so I just stop you know that
just happened that just happened to me I
can't remember what I was complimenting
I was complimenting somebody about
saying she she is a really tough person
she'd be a great prison guard and some
how can you say that I go it's a
compliment it's like what I could say I
could see this oh that's terribly you
would say that I go no that's a
compliment in an odd way that shows
their sex and because shouldn't be
shouldn't women be allowed to be prison
guards or anything they want to be
that's what I should have said
by the way you know it's pretty it's
pretty funny when we couldn't remember
Gordon Ramsay a minute ago you said
before what do you call that room of
people with the facts would you say that
was the brain room the brain room I've
just got a window here where a guy yells
at me so it's like it's a little it's a
little different
alright so just to kind of wrap we could
do this all day and it's a pleasure
talking to you and all that stuff and we
will do this in person for sure but I
want to end on because we've only said
the T word the the Trump word I think it
was only lasted for about 20 seconds and
I do want to talk about it for a second
because I don't think you were at least
at first a huge supporter I think you
basically when I've done stuff with you
I sense that you're really trying to
make some sense of what's going on here
I think you kind of get the way he's
playing the media which I've tried to
address to me they're all liars he's
just lying in a different way but he is
lying too and what what at this point is
your is your end answer with him or at
least what are you feeling right now I
think he is doing a pretty decent job
when he lets things do their job I think
like the Hurricanes and stuff the
preparations but then he kind of steps
in it
and that and then that creates a lot of
mistakes and a lot of a lot of conflict
but I have to say that he's doing okay I
decided to give him the benefit of the
doubt when he became president we're not
when there are other options I was going
like I had I I pretty much was thinking
Rubio I like me and I was like Jim Webb
that wasn't that his name James Webb
yeah Jim Webb yeah that point that poor
guy he was running for a party that left
like 40 years before you know he was
just an interesting guy you know but
anyway um I had to like you know I was
going like my problem with Trump is that
it was taking ideas that I and other
people have talked about it and kind of
like treating them roughly so that like
it doesn't sound as good except that
he's making it persuasive to a certain
group of people but he's making it he's
twisting it in a way that is not as
elegant I guess and that would drive me
crazy it's like it's like ah that's now
that's not how you should do it and then
I realized that a lot of times I'm not
getting it that he's he's taking it to
in a different
to a different audience it's like when
he was making jokes that I that people
were upset about about like McCain and I
was I thought that was a poor joke to
make then I realized if it was a roast
it was a great joke like if he said that
you know it would have been it would
have and that's how he thinks he feels
that he's a performer out there and he
doesn't really mean it
he doesn't mean that he's not a hero
it's just an insult that would have
worked on a Comedy Central Roast for
Senator McCain if he said ah he's not
everybody says he's a hero but you're
not here if you don't get caught people
would have laughed I suddenly when I
took it out of the context of politics
and put it in that context I saw what he
was when I realized what a different
what a different kind of candidate he
was and how different that was to me and
then I had this realization that why a
lot of people on cable didn't like him
we said he was the first cable news for
actually the first FoxNews president he
took incorporated a lot of stuff that he
had been but it been ingesting for a
decade and he made it he turned it he
put it through his filter and then
became this phenomenon and I think you
know I one talk show hosts say to me I
could have done that like he's talking
about so he goes
well you didn't he did and I think
that's why like I do I think like I
don't know I don't talk to Glenn Beck
but I kind of think Glen Beckett was
looking at this and going like therefore
the I could have done that why did I
knew that I had the following I could
have done that but I didn't he did it
and it kind of bugs me and it's like I
think we're seeing a guy that took ideas
that you know that were I think even
from shows that he watched on Fox mm-hmm
and then he went out there and he
performed and he did a you know he did a
phenomenal job I mean it was so
phenomenal that it surprised everybody
yeah go ahead that's the well just
quickly that's the interesting thing is
I'll see people say well you know I'm
actually okay with what he's done or
hasn't done or I'm okay with some
deregulation where the title nine thing
actually was bad or whatever else but
then they'll say oh I wish he could just
stop tweeting and I'll go yeah like I
don't really like the tweets I don't
comment on them because I'm not trying
to add to the madness but how can you
tell the guy who did it his way and one
despite all odds well now just do it the
way everyone wants you to it just
doesn't stand to reason regardless what
you think of Trump
yeah exactly you know what I was
thinking about this the other day I was
going I was critical of his behavior
although his behavior was very similar
to my own
and I'm wondering like I'm I've said
cruel things I've said tacky things
onset speeches i-i've made inappropriate
jokes and I wondered if I went if I ran
for president would I change my behavior
I probably I probably wouldn't so how
can I blame him for not changing his I
mean how can i yeah how can I blame him
for not being him he's himself saying
did you just did you just announce for
2020 is that what just happened there
yes exactly
no there's no way I will ever run for
office I wanted to run for mayor I keep
thinking about that of New York as I
can't stand DeBlasio but I don't you
know I just don't have the I'm you know
what I'm low-energy Greg all right say
I'm low-energy Greg I just don't have
the energy it's like again one of the
great labels of 20 of 2016 Low Energy AB
but know it's there yeah not me
maybe yes and you should may I mean if I
go full Abe Lincoln I guess maybe I
could but probably I will listen for a
low energy guy you're doing a great job
over there I think you're one of the the
people that I try to point to people of
look the guys trying to figure it out
and and I know person I won't even
mention some of the some of the names
that we both come across of people we
admire that are all over the political
map that that I know you get your
information from and I think that's a
good thing so you guys can check out the
Greg Gutfeld show on Saturday nights 10
p.m. right 10 p.m. exactly 10 p.m.
Eastern on Fox News and he's on the 5
which apparently is moving to 5 o'clock
we we cracked a story here today
points at some points and shall find out
and be nine o'clock this week
nothing clock this week attentively 5
o'clock in the future and all right next
time we're doing this in person my
friend you got it I'll see you soon I
hope all right thanks oh and follow him
on Twitter it's at Greg Gutfeld
there you go
you
[Music]